how's a guy that's been married nearly
for 30 years write a book about how to
be an alpha male and rational male well
first off um i think you need to uh
define what is an alpha male that is a
beta male when i talk about alpha or
beta i'm talking about in term like
abstract terms so it's not like i'm the
the comparison isn't we're like
silverback gorillas or you know wolves
on the arctic tundra or something like
that it's it's a placeholder term it's
an abstraction so to say there are guys
who are of a higher class or of a higher
value than there are of guys who are you
know just sort of around the middle guys
average average men right now
so when when you say something like
alpha or beta people want to turn it
into sort of like scientific terms like
etymological terms right they want to
say well you guys are just comparing
yourselves to you know gorillas or
something like that it has nothing to do
with it whatsoever so
defining what that is the book is not
necessarily meant to say okay here's how
you be an alpha male kind of thing what
my work has done over the course of the
last 20 years now
has been to explore intersectional
dynamics as a part of that yes male
nature is a part of that female nature
is a part of that and how do those two
natures play on each other
and how do they do that from a mac or a
micro level to a macro level so all you
know all the way down to you know uh
what it what is it that makes a guy
attractive what is it that makes a woman
attractive and then from that point from
that point forward it's how do they come
together how do they have sex how do
they form families and from those
families how do they form tribes from
those tribes how do they form nations
how in and on and on and on but you have
to go all the way back and sort of
distill it down to the intersexual
dynamics between men and women and
that's what i attempted to do in the
first book and then i've got uh well
three other books since then that are
just supplements to the to the first
book rollo before you became this
rational male like you guys were kind of
doing a community college competition
over here who had a better community
college upbringing in past days
pcc
but was this did you go to school for
this did you learn you know on the go
were you out were you a party guy well
like as pat always asked like who were
you in high school like did you have a
situation that happened like a girl
broke your heart like that's never going
to happen again everyone how did this
happen okay so this is standard is this
standard question 101 okay
so
so first thing is i've been married for
25 years as of july of last year
so thank you and um
so people always ask me that how did you
come into this you know this situation
did somebody break your heart was there
some point like well how did you get red
pill kind of thing
and it was a more like a slow process
not necessarily some sort of you know
break breakup or anything any like
there's no catalyst to you know oh well
i'm gonna this is gonna make this my
life's mission it wasn't about that it
was just curiosity for a very long time
uh i grew up as i said in southern
california um i was part of like say the
the late 80s early 90s you know metal
scene that was going on in in hollywood
at the time
thanks
and so from there you know i kind of got
my act together after after a while um i
mean i've been through bad breakups just
like anybody else has but that was not
necessarily the catalyst for me to say
okay this is what i'm gonna do
uh i have had a very i say unique set of
circumstances over the course of my life
so uh going from uh from that situation
from southern california just sort of
being a
a kid really in my 20s um wanting to
have a good time wanting to party wanted
to get you know it certainly was about
the money back then it was more about
getting laid so um that was my my
impetus at that point and then of course
you mature you get a little bit older uh
you know i met my wife uh in a lake
tahoe area
and um and so from that point you know
you have kids and you sort of you know
reassess where it is and what you want
to do and set goals for yourself and you
know sort of mature um i'm generation x
so maybe that's that had something to do
with it as well
we have a lot of listeners that are what
18 to 40 give or take for the most part
some are single some are getting out of
college some are in relationships some
are married
what's the outcome of this conversation
just so we're all on the same page is it
to expose what's really going on out
there you're going to drop some
knowledge hey this is what you guys got
to do to improve your life
where are we going just so we can set
the tone okay conversation so the the if
there is a a purpose or a point to my
writing it is to educate okay it is to
educate guys to give them the tools so
that they can make informed decisions
when it comes to their personal life
first and foremost and second of all
from that point where do you go from
there how do you change your life i am
not in the business of making men better
men i am in the business of giving men
the tools so that they can make
themselves better men i in i'm in the
business of not prescriptions but
descriptions and so what happens is then
people will take those guys will take
those and better their lives save their
save their own lives and in many
instances as well
um and then it's not just about getting
laid a lot of people want to want to
mischaracterize what it is that i do and
say well it's just those pickup artists
it's just those you know we're talking
about pickup artists in 2022
about pickup artists that were in in the
scene back in 2002. so we're talking
about 20 years
the game by the way was published in
2005.
all the events in there took place
between like say 20 or 2002 and 2000 so
fair to say the game has changed very
much so and that's the i think we we
want to run back to that when we want to
mischaracterize when we want to uh we
want to just dismiss and ridicule all of
that but it has matured to the point
where it used to be just about you know
pua and like how do i get laid guys come
together on forums they start comparing
notes it's sort of this aggregate of
information between guys
is the first time in history where we
had the internet where guys could get
together and sort of compare notes all
over the world and from that point it
was it snowballed from there into
how do i live a better life how do i how
do i find uh if that's what they wanted
to do how do i find a girlfriend it's
not all about notch count a lot of guys
use the red pill just so they can get a
girlfriend in the first place or go from
you know being a quote unquote perma
virgin to you know getting getting a
girlfriend or you know getting into a
situation where they're in a
relationship at that point so it's it's
all about what you do with it rather
than okay well it's ju this is the point
this is the importance of it it doesn't
have any particular point to it it's a
praxology not an ideology so if you
enjoy this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]